ces trous sont les traces des
bombardements de la seconde guerre
mondiale pour reconstituer la forêt
ravage et des résineux à croissance
rapide avait été planté dans les années
70 des résineux a battu aujourd'hui sur
cinq hectares que l'office national des
forêts remplace par des chaînes car plus
petraglia sur le chêne rouvre en latin
des chaînes de la région centre mais pas
seulement deux essences plus méridional
sont plantés en cette fin d'année sur un
hectare une parcelle qui servira de
laboratoire pour tester la résistance de
ces arbres face au réchauffement
climatique
ça permettra aux forestiers dans 15 ans
10 ans 15 ans 20 ans de se décider en
disant ah on a planté ça mais ça s'est
vraiment bien bien réagi parce que ce
qui est constaté aujourd'hui déjà ces
trois choses les deux années que vient
de vivre la 2018-2019 donc sécheresse
intense humidité de l'air qui a
quasiment disparu voilà les seuls qui se
dessèchent et les températures extrêmes
les menuisiers charpentiers de la
fédération française du bâtiment
constate d'ailleurs une diminution des
ressources en chaîne j'ai il ya des
grands et puis allez petit les petits
c'est pour faire tout le reste de la
basse alsace et passage voilà et ça
c'est le passage comme ça ils se sont
donc engagés à financer cette plantation
de différentes variétés pour préserver
leurs matières premières deux chaînes de
poitou et le chêne de gascogne venant
donc du sud de la france ses deux essais
deux variétés de chaînes devraient mieux
supporter l'élévation de la température
et donc nous permettre d'utiliser encore
et toujours notre ressource locale 125
arbres sont plantés actuellement dans le
cadre des 125 ans de la fédération
française du bâtiment 2500 autres
suivront d'ici la fin de l'année